hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at [ __ ]
boys my hiccups are now gone but I have
no doubt that they will return at a very
inconvenient time but besides that I
have to take another shot because it's
just about that time again so god this
is fun
did I mention that I'm having funnier
did I mention that this is totally
awesome in everywhere cheers everybody
whoever's drinking long don't know who
about a breath
I started this episode off a little too
excited oh oh man whoa Jesus
okay I'm to the point where I'm almost
white-girl wasted okay so we got an
objective here what I need to do is I
only have one camera left that I need to
kill I'm pretty sure anyway and that
camera is in the main office but before
I do that because I've been able to get
these other people in my crew I'm gonna
try to get withered foxy if he's just
not gonna be a son of a [ __ ] and decide
that he's actually gonna cooperate with
me and hopefully but try back up bash it
has a high chance of missing but
everybody said I needed to do back up
back god stop it with a spread bomb I
don't have a spread heal you [ __ ] oh god
damn it that's gonna miss so many times
God so [ __ ] guys just like he does to
spread bombs and I'm dead there's like
nothing else I can do about it just
because it's like that's all there is to
it like I can't I can't seem to like do
what I need to do so it's just like I'm
a [ __ ] bunnyhop I know I know I know
oh he's paralyzed good well that does
nothing I might as well have whether
Bonnie tried to do back a bash alright
oh he's no longer oh he's no longer
stunned okay that's okay
yes okay this is going okay so long as
he doesn't do another [ __ ] spread
bomb which I know he's gonna do because
he's an [ __ ] big bass beat the Bears
beat the bass back a [ __ ] might as well
haven't try okay
charge up yeah 21,000 and he's not dead
holy [ __ ] holy goddamn oh he's still
stunned oh I thought he wasn't stunned
oh he's still stunned oh my god that's
awesome holy [ __ ] you guys we're not
kidding about backup bass because my god
why wasn't I do it backup bash please do
foxy I need you in my night of
debauchery so now I have two chances to
paralyze someone because I got all these
[ __ ] on my side this is awesome this
is so cool I'm doing so good I don't
know how much is left in the game
because I've almost beaten all the
cameras by now get the [ __ ] out of here
you little streamer [ __ ] man I'll be
like what else is there left to do I've
got seven people seven people in my crew
where are they so spread out like that
what
what what what the [ __ ] is that what the
[ __ ] is that what the [ __ ] is that
I don't know what that is holy [ __ ] what
is that I didn't I didn't I didn't I
didn't oh my god what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ]
I'm in a loss I have no idea what's
happening what is going on
I haven't feel like that this guy is
gonna be really really really tough oh
babe I didn't I didn't heal up anything
I didn't get more items in here ah [ __ ]
oh my god I didn't heal up from the last
fight like I'm [ __ ]
walk the plank be paralyzed yes okay I
don't know how much life this guy asked
but Lisa's stunned which is good I don't
know why surrounded by the other dudes
okay
Healing Wingham as well start healing
people up again
no Mangal you do large soda on toy
Bonnie you pizza pass to mangle you back
up ash and you rush down god that does
not do as much as I thought it was
supposed to damn it that bag of bash
it's finicky but it is good when it
happens like I don't know what the point
is this is like why is this gonna be
something special that I was supposed to
do because holy [ __ ] okay
[ __ ] I'm almost out of [ __ ] who needs it
no one needs it okay parable [ __ ] back
up ash flank walk come on yes paralyze
you [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] how much life to the sky have
holy [ __ ] duck oh my god this is awesome
okay you need large soda on Freddy you
need large soda on not mangle I'm angle
okay oh [ __ ] you need large soda on toy
Bonnie or withered Bonnie plank-walking
just in case like you never know maybe I
could paralyze him again
[Music]
come on geez how much health do you have
oh [ __ ] is it like when he actually is
able to do something to me it's gonna be
unreal and death-defying and I'm gonna
run out of time aren't I can you do that
you do that I need to hurry the [ __ ] up
back abashed plank walk go go go come on
come on bud
bah bah bah paralyze yes good good good
come on I'm gonna run a time RT holy
[ __ ] I'm gonna run time more straight up
out of time ah [ __ ] come on come on come
on buck
come on what yes that is paralyzing so
much more than it has in the past God if
my backup bass would [ __ ] work
holy [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
Go Go Go Go come on come on come on come
on come on come on damn it
[ __ ] a duck come on oh [ __ ]
ah come on what the [ __ ] what's that
[ __ ] me Jesus head [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] okay
geez son it'll always help this guy has
oh [ __ ] me come on [ __ ] ah [ __ ] I have
no idea if Liz like important to do but
I mean it feels like it's very rare like
I wondered why the two things were split
like that like god damn holy [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] I mean even if I beat him now like
the puppets gonna get me like that's
like nothin I can do about that now
I have no idea if I'm even close
oh [ __ ] well that's it for me then okay
well maybe I don't know if I should keep
trying nope too late
damn damn what was that guy what was the
point of that why was that a thing that
was so nuts what the [ __ ]
oh god I'm all the way back here [ __ ]
duck wait oh no did I did I not save
after did I okay no I got I got foxy
okay that's good god damn it holy [ __ ]
that was like nuts like what the [ __ ]
happened
I have no goddamn idea don't do it again
please dear dear God I don't have I
better have time to do it again okay so
now I need to get actually I don't have
enough tokens because I just bought
everything that I need you okay what I'm
gonna do after that is I'm just gonna
fight the last camera because I think
there's only one left okay we're all
good here let's get out here before I
meet the plushie again Jesus no okay
good you just by yourself oh that failed
really well this guy's gonna get the ass
ramming of his life don don don don don
don don okay time to fight the last
camera get the [ __ ] out of our way come
on thank you thank you for cooperating
no what was that well [ __ ] you god damn
it
thank you there's two boxes here I
didn't know that these boxes were gonna
be here okay so now that I got these I
can learn the ultimate combos for these
guys okay all right so cool cool cool
cool [ __ ] god damn it [ __ ] no thank you
Jesus god damn okay so now I need to
heal [ __ ] Freddy back up so now we're
ready good question yes absolutely do
that
okay engage that guy ah do that no no no
ah [ __ ] para volt uh back a Bosch flank
walk okay
Go Go Go Go Go Go Go I don't have time
for this Scott doing out all the
although like yes paralyzed good good
good good good
[ __ ] those guys hurt like a [ __ ]
god damn it come on
yes paralyzed another one okay I gotta
beat these hats because holy [ __ ] god
dammit come on spread bomb good good
good good
it's a pass to you oh [ __ ]
back a bash come on plank walk paralyze
them paralyze him [ __ ] paralyze them yes
okay better than isn't better than what
I was expecting okay he's dead good good
good good good good good good good good
good I can do this ah [ __ ] that backup
bash doesn't do a goddamn thing okay
good good good
Bam Bam Bam done done you okay oh no it
is so tense but I'm like I'm like really
into it really into it I'll [ __ ] foxy
went down
and you're done okay good good good good
good
oh yeah brother
oh good you were fools all of you but
watching through the cameras entire time
thank you I need to save oh [ __ ]
shut the [ __ ] up no yard oh [ __ ] okay I
got okay I ain't going back to there
it's just yet because I need to save
like a [ __ ]
Jesus no get out of my way you [ __ ] okay
so now here puppet goddamnit [ __ ] out of
my way oh come on
thank you alright so now everything is
kind of weird and wonky but it's better
because I got at least I got like this
no I don't need more of those okay
alright so now I have everything that I
need to be able to do what I need to do
okay
cake up this guy excuse me sorry that
was very rude of me
and now I'll medium soda everybody okay
now everybody's back to full so what
else do I need to do here besides go and
[ __ ] up Balloon Boy cuz I know he's
gonna be a tough fight but is he gonna
be that tough of a fight that's like
that's the question here because I
compared to like the plushie Jesus I
almost like I I feel like I almost beat
the plushie but I just wasn't like close
enough man I wish I could've beat that
plus you if friggin bull bling back up
bash Joey you finally arrived inhale my
dong in made a good [ __ ] let me tell
you a little story
no I don't have time for a story I was
the NPC's child one way dry ties and my
peel from the influence of humanity's
many evils death and countless I'm
ground ivy as Isis success Tommy I
defeated chameleon defeat I began
research forbidden no no you [ __ ]
dumbass
I traveled through time to put fat bear
and timid I'll visit boy they could have
a room I like talking about destroying
you however there's one way I could pay
you join me we could rule together
forever will could be yours Helen oh how
about Obama no clock's ticking here wait
what what what the [ __ ] what does happen
hello the [ __ ] uh I guess I'm done here
what the [ __ ] what happened whoa what
this is earthbound this is the last
level earthbound what the stick from
earlier began chains grew new drag until
the way what the [ __ ] why why am I alone
ok there's less so cool well that does
like less what is it better I don't know
I guess I'll try it okay then fine oh
this is trippy
it is [ __ ] trippy as hell this is
totally the last oh my god it's guy
gasps as its earthbound guy gasps Jesus
don't kill yourself already
Yahweh yourself though so it's a
pre-compression of time I have become
the most powerful creature no no there's
nothing but a desolate hope left for
this world
what's up done with you Freddy [ __ ] boy
inhale my dog oh [ __ ] BB appeared well
good because I death inhales Jesus he's
gonna inhale my dong so good oh Jesus
goddamn it oh [ __ ] dammit Jesus god damn
it [ __ ] it doc the guy hurt too badly
okay I have a feeling that like I don't
know if the uh I don't know if it's
exactly what I should be doing with the
dragon dildo because it dropped my
attack by like a lot so what was the
point of that thing I'm fine all right
you know what I'm gonna switch back to
my other thing cuz I mean obviously
right here it says oh the dragon deal
they'll also increase defense
okay well optimize it it says that I'm
doing the right thing so fine why not
you know I'm gonna do it because the
death and hail is there I'm gonna guard
but a guard over and over again to the
point where I'll be able to do what I
need to do okay guard now that's still
hurt anyway why did that hurt
Jesus you [ __ ] hurt like a son of a
[ __ ]
whoa but we're toy Bonnie come from all
right then I guess I just needed to wait
enough the [ __ ] okay so I need to get at
the point where I can do death and Hale
oh no that's my normal that's my normal
attack okay that's my normal combo
ultimate thing
god damn it [ __ ] you ah yeah piece of
[ __ ] okay good for you baby [ __ ] you
death inhale [ __ ] you up the Boyd's come
on death inhale okay
I don't know if these are doing these
are all different okay then holy [ __ ]
nice nice this is nice I like this holy
[ __ ] the combo is actually working this
time whereas before it didn't work
necessarily oh man why am I so giddy I
don't know this is going really well but
how much health does this [ __ ] have at
least I'm not on a time limit that's
like really good [ __ ] this taking a
while I guess we're just gonna be
sitting or enjoying the show it's like
one of the final fantasy summons like
Jesus they take forever
okay we're done are we done Jesus oh
[ __ ]
status bomb yay okay Bonnie's dead but
that's okay Jesus
uh I need to get him up
dun dun dun dun Jesus guy has a lot of
health uh a timer flip okay fine why I
don't know why that's necessary but I'm
gonna try it
god damn why did toy Bonnie's tech go
down like I thought toy Bonnie's tech
was like going way up
goddamn this hardest [ __ ] Jesus this
guy's too tough okay fine
Jesus like this is really tough I don't
know how much health this guy has like I
wish I was a way to find out like
exactly how much health these guys do
have because holy [ __ ] there's like
[ __ ] heart is [ __ ] yeah there we go
mangles here okay hopefully I can
paralyze them stop healing yourself you
[ __ ] at least they don't heal enough
that it out does the damage that I'm
doing skill you do that lolani scream
scream skills parable there you go come
on come on [ __ ] mommy does he doesn't be
like all that much damage he does a lot
of damage but like not all that much
that it makes a significant difference
on what I'm doing here
Oh God not a spread bomb [ __ ] Jesus how
much help you have you [ __ ] Oh God let's
take you forever jesus [ __ ] duck god
damn it [ __ ] it's like really
complicated I really have to think about
what I'm doing I really want to paralyze
him but Jesus it doesn't do it all that
often okay
status bomb still damn it I don't have
enough skill free please paralyze him
god damn it okay all right come on Jesus
how much help do you have
[Music]
oh [ __ ] please paralyze them yes yes yes
yes yes yes okay got it got it got it
okay in the bag in the bag in the back
all right cool cool cool all right [ __ ]
death inhale [ __ ]
all right ah [ __ ] I'm only down to
medium pizzas [ __ ] I got this then we
okay come on how many times do I got to
do this seriously
you guys is bear with me this is gonna
take a while
Jesus sorry you guys have to sit through
all this cuz holy [ __ ] this guy not dead
yet seriously like how much more does
this guy need come on well okay that was
fun
all right whatever ah I guess keep using
the medium pizzas because of the point
here it's gonna be real bad I keep
trying to parable para joltin yay holy
[ __ ] that was ad only need four hundreds
left okay cool I was I mean okay cool so
it isn't over yet find me if you can
haha withered body rejoin the party okay
good later chica later inhale into the
party inhale
yes need whoa that's weird
holy [ __ ] goddamn it this is so gah gas
is so guy gassed I'm just finding a
whole bunch of cakes awesome I guess Hey
look there he is
let me actually like rejuvenate myself
[Music]
okay they can't do anything but if I do
Bonnie's heal Bonnie can heal up without
using what I need okay Jesus like
goddamn okay so either way I think I'm
done with this part here I will get to
the final balloon boy I guess in the
next episode so thank you everybody so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always
[Music]